Anlegen für den finalen Schuss.
Großwildjäger begeistert auf der Jagd:
“Das sind Leute, die Tiere abschießen für
Profite, die konsumieren afrikanische Wildtiere."
Schüsse in eine Elefantenherde – ein blutiges
Vergnügen.
Sogenannte Trophäenjagden sind ein Riesengeschäft.
“Wir gehen ja nicht und schiessen die Tier
zum Spaß und töten die einfach nur so. Darum
geht es ja nicht.”
Auch tausende Deutsche machen jedes Jahr in
afrikanischen Ländern Jagd auf Elefant, Nashorn
und Co. Und bringen ihre geschossenen Trophäen
mit nach Hause. Ganz legal und vom Staat erlaubt.
Wir stoßen im Netz auf diese verstörenden
Videos. Hobby-Jäger filmen sich, wie sie
bedrohte Wildtiere erschießen und danach
mit ihren Trophäen prahlen.
Unsere Recherche beginnt 2019 hier: Dortmund.
Jedes Jahr präsentieren sich die Anbieter
solcher Trophäenjagden auf der “Jagd und
Hund”-Messe.
“Sehr beliebt zur Zeit sind die Big 5. Das
heißt Büffel, Leopard, Löwe, Elefant. Und
Rhino, ne.” –
"Elefanten, Giraffen..
Wechseln sich von 30 000 bis 65 000 Euro."
Wir wollen wissen, was den Reiz dieser Jagden
ausmacht.
"Wir gehen ja nicht und schiessen die Tiere
zum Spaß und töten die einfach nur so. Darum
geht es ja nicht."
"Es geht nicht um Spaß?" –
"Nein, nein. Es gehört einfach dazu für uns."
"Aber für den Kunden ist es auch Spaß,
oder?"
"Es ist ein Erlebnis. Ein Erlebnis."
"Das ist alles Geschäft." –
"Aber Sie bieten ja die Jagdreisen an?"
"Ja, aber weil es ein Geschäft ist. Es ist
wie ein Industriebetrieb, das ist alles Geschäft
im Leben."
Aber nicht alle Aussteller wollen mit uns
reden.
"Bitte verlassen Sie den Stand!" –
"Christian Esser vom ZDF"
"Ja, das kann jeder behaupten. Ja, Entschuldigung,
und bitte wir wollen kein Interview geben.
"Warum nicht?"
"Wir haben unsere Gründe, ok?"
Deutschland ist drittgrößte Trophäenjagdnation.
Der Import abgeschossener Tiere ist legal
– selbst wenn sie unter Artenschutz stehen.
Allein 2019 wurden 748Trophäen aus der ganzen
Welt nach Deutschland eingeführt. Darunter
19 getötete Elefanten.
Dieser Mann hat noch bis vor einigen Jahren
dafür die Einfuhrgenehmigungen erteilt. Dietrich
Jelden, ehemaliger Abteilungsleiter im Bundesamt
für Naturschutz. Jetzt hält er Vorträge für den
internationalen Jagdverband.
“Ich meine mit der Auslandsjagd sind wichtige
ökonomische Faktoren verbunden, viele Länder,
die eine gut regulierte und nachhaltige und
legale Jagd anbieten, profitieren ökonomisch
von solchen Jagtouristen in enormen Maße.
Jagdtourismus ist ein wichtiges Instrument
im internationalen Artenschutz.”
Das wollen wir überprüfen.
Wir reisen nach Namibia – dorthin wo die
Deutschen am liebsten hinfliegen um Trophäen
zu schießen. Etwa 2500 deutsche Jäger pro
Jahr.
Wir besuchen Jofie Lamprecht in Windhoek,
der namibischen Hauptstadt. Er bietet Trophäenjagden
an. Das Besondere an seinen Reisen: Es sind
Jagden in sogenannten conservancies – in
Schutzgebieten – also dort, wo die Tiere
noch wild leben.
"Es ist Jagd, kein Töten.
Wir wollen da reingehen und es
muss spannend sein, es muss schwer sein, wir
wollen laufen, wir wollen pirschen, wir wollen
hinter diese Tier hergehen."
2019 mussten Jäger bei Jofie Lamprecht für
einen Giraffenabschuss 2000 Dollar zahlen.
Für ein Nashorn, abhängig von der Länge
des Horns bis zu 78000 Dollar und für einen
Elefanten sogar 85000 Dollar.
Es ist ein millionenschweres Geschäft, was
vor allem Hobby-Jäger aus Nordamerika und
Europa anlockt.
Jofie Lamprecht behauptet, auch die Bevölkerung
verdiene gut an der Trophäenjagd, es sei
eine wichtige Einnahmequelle für die Menschen,
die dort in Armut leben.
“Diese Leute kriegen dann meistens Geld
von der Jagd, geht direkt zu diesen Leuten
und dann können die dieses Geld benutzen
für Wasserlöcher, Schulen, Autos, das was
die nutzen in diesen Gebieten.”
Wegen jahrelanger Korruption ging aber nur ein Bruchteil des Geldes an die Menschen in den Jagdgebieten.
Daher beschloss die namibische Regierung 2018,
dass 50 Prozent der Einnahmen durch Trophäenjagden
in soziale Projekte vor Ort fließen müssen. Doch passiert das wirklich?
Wir fahren nach Omatjete, 4 Stunden von Windhoek
entfernt. Ein Gebiet, seit Jahren von Dürre
geplagt, Wasser für Mensch und Tier ist rar.
Im vergangenen Jahr wurden im Ort Wasserleitungen
verlegt. Finanziert durch eine einmalige Zahlung
aus einer Trophäenjagd.
Immer wieder ziehen Elefantenherden durch
das Dorf auf der Suche nach Wasser.
Das Gemeindeoberhaupt Ben Haakuria zeigt uns
die Wasserleitungen, die die Elefanten vergangene
Nacht aus dem Boden gerissen haben.
Geld den Schaden zu beheben und die Leitungen
tiefer zu verlegen ist nicht da, sagt er.
Eigentlich müsste regelmäßig Geld in die
Schutzgebiete aus den Trophäenjagden fließen.
Das passiere aber nicht, sagt Ben Haakuria.
Das Argument Tiere für den Artenschutz zu
töten, kann er nicht nachvollziehen.
Ein weiteres Argument der namibischen Regierung:
Trophäenjagd finanziere den Kampf gegen Wilderer.
Nashörner sind durch die Wilderei besonders
bedroht. Nashornpulver gilt vor allem in China
und Vietnam als Wundermittel. Preise von 50
Tausend Euro pro Kilo sind keine Seltenheit.
Wir wollen wissen, ob sich der Nashornbestand
in Namibia tatsächlich aufgrund der Trophäenjagd
erholt hat.
Wir machen uns auf in die Kunene Region zu
einer privaten Farm, auf der Nashörner gezüchtet
werden. Wo genau die Farm von Jaco Muller
ist, dürfen wir nicht sagen, aus Angst vor
Wilderern.
In den 80ern sollen in Namibia nur noch 50
Nashörner in freier Wildbahn gelebt haben.
Um die Ausrottung zu stoppen, wurden in den
90er Jahren die Tiere auf mehrere private
Farmen verteilt.
Mittlerweile lebt die größte Population
afrikanischer Spitzmaul-Nashörner in Namibia.
Doch von den Einnahmen der Trophäenjagd,
bekomme er keinen Cent, sagt Jaco Muller. Er hat einen
Plan, wie er den Schwarzhandel mit dem Nashorn
unterbinden könnte:
Er möchte das Horn der Tiere legal verkaufen
– denn das wächst nach. Nach einer Betäubung
der Tiere, kann es abgesägt werden.
Das Problem ist, der Verkauf der Hörner und
des daraus gewonnenen Pulvers ist durch das
Washingtoner Artenschutzabkommen weltweit verboten
Wir fahren zurück nach Windhoek, wollen wissen,
wohin fließt eigentlich das Geld aus der
Trophäenjagd und wer kontrolliert den Geldfluss?
Nachfrage beim verantwortlichen Ministerium:
Doch wenn weder der Artenschutz noch die stetige
finanzielle Unterstützung der lokalen Bevölkerung
gewährleistet ist, warum sind solche Jagdreisen
und die Einfuhr der Tiertrophäen in Deutschland
erlaubt?
Schriftlich antwortet man uns:
Januar 2020. Wir begleiten Tierschützer auf
die Messe "Jagd&Hund". Die Stimmung unter den
Reiseanbietern ist gereizt.
Wir werden von den Mitarbeitern der Messe Dortmund
nicht aus den Augen gelassen.
"Ich finde das ein bisschen seltsam, dass Sie
uns die ganze Zeit hinterherlaufen.
Wie kommt das, warum machen Sie das?"
"Wir brechen das hier ab, danke. Bitte hören
Sie auf zu drehen, ich entziehe Ihnen hiermit
die Drehgenehmigung. Danke."
Heike Henderson und Peter Rettig halten die Trophäenjagd grundsätzlich für falsch.
“Das sind Leute, die Tiere abschießen für
Profite, die konsumieren afrikanische Wildtiere
und die konsumieren am liebsten die Tiere
die es am seltensten gibt und davon noch die
Größten. Also es kann nicht nachhaltig sein.”
“Unsere Forderung ist seit mehreren Jahren
schon, dass man die Importe von diesen Trophäen
nach Deutschland beendet. Die Jagd wird es
dann immer noch geben, aber es wäre ein sehr starkes
Zeichen international, wenn Deutschland, als
drittgrößte Trophäen-Jagdnation nach USA
und Spanien, das verbieten würde.”
Die Schluss-Apotheke gefällt mir noch nicht.
Die Begründung Trophäenjagd sei eine große
Einnahmequelle für die örtliche Bevölkerung
und würde dem Artenschutz helfen ist oft
nicht standfest.
Und solange die Gelder nicht wirklich dauerhaft der lokalen Bevölkerung zu Gute kommen, wird es einfach
nur ein todbringendes Luxus-Hobby von hauptsächlich
weißen Männern sein.
Wie findet ihr die Jagd auf bedrohte Tierarten?
Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.